[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt es ein basic rezept und zwar
werde ich den herzhaften also salzigen
quark öl teig machen
diesen könnt ihr dann zum beispiel
verwenden um eine schnelle pizza zu
machen oder um den flammkuchen oder so
was ähnliches zu machen ihr könnt daraus
auch kleine teigtaschen machen die
befüllen oder teig rollen egal was der
quark öl teig ist für mich immer eine
super alternative zum hefeteig weil ich
ihn nicht aufgehen lassen muss und ihn
wirklich zu bereiten 23 minuten und dann
sofort weitermachen kann
das heißt so könnt ihr in
minutenschnelle auch mal eine richtig
leckere pizza machen
ich zeige euch hier für mal die zutaten
für das grundrezept verwende ich 300
gramm mehl ein päckchen backpulver 150
gramm magerquark etwa 40 milliliter
olivenöl 1 1 und einen teelöffel salz im
prinzip könnte jetzt einfach alle
zutaten verbinden weil es ihr keine
küchenmaschine verwendet sondern ihn mit
der hand zubereitet würde ich empfehlen
erst mal die trockenen zutaten zu
vermischen und die flüssigen und dann
alles zu verbinden und den teig könnt
ihr gerne verfeinern mit pfeffer zum
beispiel oder mit anderen kräutern
ihr könnt hier auch parmesan käse mit
reingeben und chili und so weiter ich
werde ein bisschen pfeffer zufügen und
dann zeige ich euch dass sich daraus
einmal eine pizza zubereiten und einmal
ins publikum und zwiebelkuchen
[Musik]
und je nachdem ob der belag salzig wird
oder nicht ganz so witzig müsste eben
auch hier ein bisschen weniger oder mehr
salz nehmens pfeffer rein und jetzt ganz
wichtig den teig wirklich nur kurz
zusammen kneten
[Musik]
und wenn ihr merkt dass dateien bis hin
zu trocken ist könnt ihr gern noch ein
bisschen wasser dazugeben
so sieht erstmal bröselig aus aber wenn
ihr in die hand nimmt merkt ihr das so
schön zusammen bleibt also ein richtig
schöner fester zusammen hängen den kann
ich jetzt hier rausholen zu einer kugel
formen und dann weiter verwenden
[Musik]
aus dem teig bereite ich jetzt zwei
sitzen so dass er mittels halbiert und
dann rund ausgeraubt
[Musik]
dann kommt der tag auf meine pizza blech
und wenn ihr den rand schöner haben
möchtet dann könnt ihr ihn einfach so
ein bisschen einschlagen dann ist er
außen schön glatt
[Musik]
so sieht der pizzateig gleich viel
schöner aus
jetzt kommt hier meine lieblings pizza
soße drauf da könnt ihr einfach mein
grundrezept von der pizza anschauen das
ist die die gekocht wird richtig lecker
und würzig und dann könnte sie belegen
mit den zutaten die ihr gerne habt und
so kann man wirklich schon innerhalb von
etwa 20 minuten maximum eine pizza in
den ofen schieben und hat dann innerhalb
von etwa 30 40 minuten schon eine
leckere verkaufen tisch
[Musik]
so kommen jetzt die beiden spitzen im
backofen und ich zeige ich ihnen das
zwischenzeit während die zwölf backen
ein richtig leckere zwiebelkuchen
[Musik]
den zwiebelkuchen mache ich jetzt auch
einem eckigen weg und da dann genau so
dass der rand schön wird einfach kurz
umschlagen
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt ein bisschen stand drauf
den habe ich das vorher mit salz und
pfeffer verrühren
da dürfte aber auch gerne andere gewürze
noch dazu geben
[Musik]
mit verwende ich rote zwiebeln und
hofele sie einfach nur noch hier drauf
und dann kann es auch schon gebacken
werden
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir zwei pizzen und der
zwiebelkuchen fertig ist duftet hier
richtig genial und lecker dann alle auch
schon richtig hunger und ich zeige euch
mal die konsistenz ist auch richtig gut
ich würde fast sagen wenn man es nicht
weiß weiß man nicht das ist ein
charakter ist nicht lecker aus unten
perfekt gebacken
richtig schön weich und knusprig und so
könnt ihr auf viele verschiedene arten
wirklich ganz viel tolles herzhaftes
gebäck zaubern
ihr könnt lange stangen machen die mit
kräutern bestreuen käsereien machen
wirklich seid kreativ bei mir auf dem
kanal gibt bestimmt auch noch ganz viele
weitere ideen die ich auch demnächst
noch posten werde ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen und einen guten
appetit und wir sehen uns wieder das
nächste mal jungs kommt herr jungs und
mädels zu probieren was möchtet ihr
zuerst kommt kommen fotos normal gemacht
ja okay dann können wir weiter da kommen
wir setzen uns hat sich jeder 12
[Musik]